who owns spider pig does Marvel owns is
a marvel spider pig or is it Fox inside
a pig does Homer Simpson get royalties
for spider pig what's going on
Lucy Oscar elimate with great power must
come great responsibility and Sony and
Marvel have entrusted spider-man
insomniac
we played spider-man Marvel's spider-man
will have been explicitly told to call
it Marvel's spider-man no one else's a
PlayStation 4 composer editing wall
system free it was insomniac games you
play that III we played it a couple days
ago in a central London studio and what
did you think of it what did you like
about it what did you do well I think
the thing for me is when I think of
Spider by games I was thinking
spider-man 2 and the thing I loved when
I game is how great movement felt for
any spider-man game that has to be key
and I think that's what they nailed in
Marvel's spider-man it's no they I think
I nailing because what they did is that
you see like a brief opening cutscene
and then the first thing you're doing is
you're controlling Peter Parker
spider-man as he's swinging to New York
and I'd like the biggest dumb grin on my
face because it just feels so good and
it just feels very intuitive and this is
at the end of the day it's just fun to
move in that game and I and I mean that
both in terms of just moving around the
city and also moving from enemy to enemy
when you're in combat or effort just
moving is fun and feels so fluid even
more so than I think everyone sort of
comparing Marvel's spider-man to the
Batman Arkham trilogy quadrilogy yeah
but even more so than in those that this
just feels very very fluid yeah I think
the thing that Marvel's spider-man gets
right is like the transit yeah the other
games they they felt very like staying
in the way that you'd swing like you'd
be going straight forward one of the
things that I really liked is swinging
around corners that's something that's
been really tricky to do like other
games have done it but I always felt
like turning a car and like you were
actually if you could feel like piers
and spider-man I was like taking a turn
this feels way more natural like you're
just like swinging around and then the
moves like you said like you've got a
zip zip line would say let's you like
pull yourself forward and
again Batman comparison if you get high
enough you can do like a dive and then
when you're at the bottom of your debut
swing you build the momentum back up so
that's how you get more airtime also
like pulling yourself to a point and
then hopping off like antenna and stuff
around yeah just gives you the like an
unexpected boost to speed I would say
when you like jump off a point but I
would find myself like actively
searching for those points I think the
best thing you can say about the actual
swinging is they know it's fun and they
know it's fun because there's a part of
the skill tree where you can unlock
tricks I can definitely from what I
played at e3 I can definitely see myself
just just swinging in that world and
sort of forgoing any of the story stuff
and just enjoying being there did you
get much of a sense during your demo so
imagine your demo was a little bit more
wide-ranging than mine we were the first
two hours of the game from right okay so
did you get much of a sense of how much
you can do outside of the story stuff
can you just go and swing and like you
do the first mission that New York is
completely open to you it's one of those
the really interesting things where
recently I've been really annoyed with
collectibles in open worlds and having
played this I think I've realized that
it's not the collectibles that are
annoying it's like the act of getting
the collectibles that's annoying so they
have collectibles in this game they're
actually you want to find them because
there are pieces of Peter Parker and
actual collectibles are his backpacks
that he's kind of like Webb to a wall
when he's had to in the past just break
out and do something spider-man related
but like the fact that it's so easy to
swing around and the moment you are
nearby you can like use his spider sense
and see what exactly where it is made me
want to collect them all and so that's
where I realize like if the traversal is
good the collectibles are fun to do do
you get anything for collecting those
collectibles or is it just like the
counter goes up well no so there's a
very there's various numbers of
different yeah tokens you can get so you
can get tokens for like stopping crimes
and say you get like a crime token you
get backpack tokens so collect on your
backpacks
I think you get like when you're
swinging those if you like fall a
certain amount or traverses like how
have you many thousands of feet of like
distance you get tokens for that so that
it's like another feedback that the
tokens do it yeah those feed into like
the crafting and we're upgrading stuffs
just drop you off to jail
[Music]
no not cool
[Music]
what I loved about the swing it was it's
also in the combat it has like Batman's
predatory rooms but like a lot of them I
like open-air so you can swing from one
type of room to the other
without having to like Batman needed
gargoyles and stuff like that this is
just like yeah what I love from what I
can remember playing the combat III was
how well spider-man can use his Marvel's
spider-man can use his like environment
his advantage is it almost reminds me of
Sleeping Dogs in that regard it's like
yeah you can pull like beams of concrete
down from a Construction Yard onto an
enemy's head or whatever yeah and like I
find that so satisfying in the fact that
it's not just saw pre-scripted it um is
able to adapt to where you find yourself
you know we've obviously been playing
the Batman Arkham games and it took me a
while because the combat is similar in
that it's you know same button to attack
different button to counter yeah counter
is on circle so it's like dodge instead
now b.o.b CFU spidey senses you can tell
when someone's gonna shoot at you but
what I liked is that with Batman it's
obviously all about timing and like
landing your strikes and moving on to
the next one with spider-man it's as
long as you don't get hit that counter
still goes up and then you can still
deliver those like incredible like
finishing moves you can grab environment
stuff and pull people usually your
gadgets and things and I think that's
unless even though it's faster it feels
less stressful I'm trying to keep that
combo going yeah and there's a dynamism
to everything like they've clearly spent
a lot of time making sure that the kind
of core tenants of what makes vitamin an
interesting as a character and also like
in terms of its personality and also the
way human moves
it's like represented in the combat he's
not static at all and unlike Batman
Batman is very grounded character
spider-man the combat is all about going
from ground to air and back again and
trying to do it thing that I was trying
to do was seeing if I could get through
every enemy in the room without like
breaking a loop there would be like
knocking someone into the year following
them up hitting them and with zip lining
to another guy like dodging in midair to
get extra distance and like finding the
guy who's got a gun and webbing him and
then
planning him and seeing if I can stay
off the ground while grabbing other
things from the environment this was
something I was going to ask actually
because I did the section that I played
was completely outdoors whereas I know
you played a section that was indoors
did you find because I felt spider-man
although the movement felt very good he
almost felt a little bit loose did you
find he was a bit too loose and a bit
too unwieldy at times for indoors
because all the swinging felt very sore
unnaturally long range sometimes for the
indoor stuff I think like maybe it's
part of you know their design psychology
but like it just I just changed the
approach when I was indoors there when I
was outdoors I was more inclined to like
be more mobile whereas when I was
indoors it just I think naturally just
fell into like a stealth style so it
kind of worked in the in my favor
because of that I just different change
the approach and like it does the thing
where you're crawling around vents
before you actually initiate a proper
fight right and you don't even actually
actually have to turn it into a
full-scale fight if you quietly take
everyone out you can get rid of you know
it before go that entirely but I think
so the most part I felt okay like he's
quite sticky I can be he can cling to
walls
spider-man is quite sticky marble
spider-man is very I mean the big
difference is you you obviously control
spider-man but you also control Peter
Parker doing is its day job but what I
liked about Peter Parker's day job stuff
is that he does actually have a job to
do and you get to bring them back that
pipe game from Bioshock circuit but I've
actually felt like that was kind of a
nice break in terms of gameplay because
it's kind of like doing you know when
you're in the tube and you've got like a
mobile game like a puzzle game that
you're doing just to kind of pass the
time because some of them were story
related and then it was like oh here's
this research computer go back to it
when you want to and do didn't and you
can unlock rewards by doing it but you
don't have to the Peter Parker element
of it is really important to them and we
had an interview with them and
was with the creative director Brian
into her and he was talking about how
they kind of like spoke to different
people who have worked on spider-man
over the years and came away thinking
the best stories are the ones where
spider-man and Peter Parker's worlds
collide and they're kind of like really
really like in a difficult way and
because of that this feels like an
ultimate story like it's it's in the
future they don't have the the origin
story at all anymore it's you know if he
is I think he's 23 years old he's
graduated yeah it's like the next
formative step I am sick of seeing
fungus I'm getting bitten by the spider
web and the fact that they kind of so
many times they skip over that it like
it it shows that they're in tune with
the audience I think they know and
they're confident in the story that they
have they don't have to rely on that old
thing I love the fact that they picked
mr. negative to be their main villain
like that's not someone that they
traditionally would have most people
will never don't even know mr. negative
is if you're like a spider-man fan who
goes through the movies similar with
Lexi we'll say it's silver sable and all
these other like side characters like
Yuri Watanabe who could become Rafe and
that kind of stuff so it's a lot of
fanservice but also taking characters
that people don't know and they have a
little more leeway to do interesting
things with them you know Mary James in
it and a lot of amazed in it and Miles
Morales is in it like we didn't see him
in our you know thing but like that's
another Spiderman walking around
potentially they've got the pieces of a
really interesting story and from what
I've seen of it and what they say it
looks like it could be really cool when
they've they're setting up some a big
kind of like oh crap moment for Peter
Parker and I'm really interested in
seeing how it all comes together as soon
as the six are in it so you know you're
gonna get the kind of like the
traditional spider-man bill in the
stories as well but I'm really excited I
haven't been this excited for a
superhero's story in a game in a long
time since the Arkham games there's not
been very many
since but I'm excited about on a level
on the same level I was excited
as for Arkham yeah I can't feel like
sort of a shout out because I was kind
of worried about like the humor cuz
pizza is as a character he's he's very
funny he's very glib and I was afraid
that maybe that would great as you're
playing as him but honestly like I
thought the writing is really good and
there's a bit where he's um you kind of
you and Yuri are working together and
she's basically sending you in you know
she doesn't want to commit the police
forces in case it's an it becomes an
incident but she can kind of send piece
of park well she can sense why in my
name and he created this onel persona
for himself and what was it like to call
hi to call would you look at that
already when Spyder cops on the job come
hell or high water good job kids she'd
never admit it but the chief was warming
up to spider cut the writing is really
cool like it's clear that they've spent
time like like they talked about having
context contextual comedy so it's like
they've clearly picked the moments where
they want the comedy to happen and when
you when you get there in the story or
in the world and trigger that stuff then
it is it makes sense for it to be there
instead of it just being like will write
a series of quips and then they'll heal
spout it when you learn the three hit
combos or something like that it's
clearly like focused and very like
sharply driven they also have like a
like another thing that they're
borrowing is the tower mechanic so like
they've got the Assassin's Creed style
towers but it's like you can do that
straight away and it was just like I was
thing about the collectables it's so
easy to just swing onto a rooftop where
the tower is that the first thing I
wanna do was like oh I'm just gonna find
all the towers yeah so that is the kind
of like indicative of what this game is
starting to feel like they've taken a
bunch of ideas that aren't necessarily
unique but they've reinterpreted them
and made them work for the game that
they're working on and made them work
for spider-man and they haven't
compromised a character and they've
retained the fun in those mechanics and
made it more enjoyable because they've
thought about how spider-man would
interact with it
it's an exciting game I'm it's quickly
gone to the top of like my most
anticipated list I mean I'm not a huge
fan of anything Marvel or spider-man
really yeah and I'm really looking
forward to it just from my I played at
e3 yeah so it's just a very fun game to
play Marvel spider cops Marvel's Michael
was fight a cop come on I want to know
where the spider pig exists in this
universe who owns spider pig does Marvel
owns but is a Marvel spider pig or is it
[ __ ] spider pig does Homer Simpson
get royalties for spider pig what's
going on